throughout the many years of competitive
dota 2 heroes have come and gone as the
meta changed over time but some heroes
have gained a significance that goes far
beyond just one or two metas so we're
counting down the top 10 most important
heroes in DotA 2 history as the all-time
most picked hero in competitive play by
nearly 2000 Rubik has been a staple of
the pro scene since his release he
offers excellent ganking and the ability
to change games with a single
well-executed spells field he sleeps
itself or steps away trying to get to
Vince's death really but will not be
able to get away from has become the
signature hero of countless players and
has been a key element in some of dota
twos most famous and dramatic moments
[Applause]
the presence of a skilled Rubik player
in any match makes opponents thinks
twice about throwing out their big
spells and can change the course of a
game in a blink of an eye
players love playing him and fans love
watching him what more can you ask for
since the very start of dota 2 anti-mage
has been one of the gold standards for
carry heroes and has defined the careers
of countless pros such as burning and
maybe noble that's their own telekinesis
but they will still kill off mag another
kill now for burning this is especially
true for dota twos first year anti-mage
was the most banned and the tenth most
picked hero at ti1
however regardless of meta when
anti-mage is popular he is a force to be
reckoned with has he gotten the racks
yet though they're gonna have to pack
away they for something Sankey buyback
secret do hold for now but a blink a
stunt a counter initiation and that a
counter to the counter initiation it
comes down to this for the past eight
years the ability to play an teammates
wealth has been one of the bars by which
all position when players are judged he
has been and will continue to be a
defining hero for carry players as long
as dota is played
while he may have only been added to
captain's mode in December 2015
Earth Spirit has become an essential
part of the competitive meta his
ridiculous long-range ganking and
ability to roam easily and effectively
empowered position for players allowing
names such as jer acts to build their
reputations on the hero earth spirit is
the 45th most contested hero of all time
ahead of much older staples like Night
Stalker Magnus and dragon beautiful play
from job earth spirit changed the way
teams think about pick and band and
forever changed the roaming for role and
that's why he comes in at number eight
[Applause]
shadow fiend has traditionally done with
position two players as anti mage is
done for carry players becoming the bar
by which their ability is judged and
therefore gaining a significance far
beyond mere numbers to your suit well I
did that burning it's a trap shadow
fiend is a signature hero of countless
players like Ferrari 430 RTZ and mushi
and has a legacy as a de facto hero for
1v1 s while other picks such as queen of
pain or puck have felt similar roles
neither have the same sort of histories
or mystique about them
ultra fart or unstoppable shadowfiend
was most popular in the first three
years of dota 2 but players like our TZ
did for a time revolutionized SS as a
stable safe flame pic giving the hero
and added significance and with the
relocate out they don't need to get the
kilim that fronted RIT came to stand up
an old truck hilf amid once he just
reads every push and rampaging firm
everything pgj office will it be a
double null word MP will take it look at
it this way when players face off
against the open AI which hero do they
play shadow fiend of course that alone
should indicate how important SF is to
the competitive scene of dota 2 going in
[Applause]
in many ways invoker is to the new
generation of players what shadowfiend
was to the old a hero on which they can
measure their skill and prove their
immense mechanical talents supa Shiva's
God connects there's the Sun strike BAM
miracle does it while invoker isn't meta
defining he's absolutely game changing
the game to game impact and longevity of
invoker is what makes the hero so
important to the history of the scene
thanks to invoker's flexibility in skill
build and item build
he has rarely if ever fallen out of meta
finally as the fourth most contested
hero of all time invoker is always
relevant exerts a tremendous amount of
pac-man pressure and must be dealt with
in any game in which he is paying whoa
looks like he'll be able to make it out
in trouble here but the onslaught
continues as se gets the next site going
down and taking out crit now sumail and
our tseebo flick the tag team home but
he's gonna be able to get up the tornado
he gets the false promise and says back
the hell off
Chen was the earth spirit of his day
defining what it meant to play position
four from around 2011 to 2013
while his popularity since then has gone
up and down Chen was a meta shaping
support pick during the first three
years of dota 2 his ganking threat and
ability to push towers early was make a
break for certain strategies during that
time period and he was a signature hero
in the careers of many of the best
supports of that era including puppey
chuan and Aki
very few heroes in the early days of
dota 2 had such a widespread and
dramatic impact across the board but
Chen was one of them but what makes Chen
truly stand out is that he has the
all-time highest win rate of any hero
going to show just how impactful he can
be in the right hands a Chen will take
that weapon no matter the metaphor the
offlane dark seer has found a home
lending his terrifying team fighting to
just about any composition he was a
premier pick back when the offlane was a
deathtrap
and even as the offline meta gradually
became more stable dark sneer made the
transition where others while he's had
periods where he's fallen out of favor
they tend to be short and when he's in
he's in dark seer has been the hero
against which all other offliners are
judged for the better part of seven
years basically every offliner of note
was ever played dota 2 he probably has a
dark seer in their arsenal whether they
like it or not the pic is that important
to the history of the offlane role and
third bubble guard out ever since the
game's beginning nature's prophet has
been single-handedly winning games and a
good prophet player shapes the game
around themselves smashing through the
faces of liquid Buddha with the crush
it's gonna be a killing spree for the
slaughter prophet is a hero that has
rarely if ever fallen out of favor
no matter the meta prophet has found
brew and be awfully the jungle safely or
even the middling
he's flexible rewards strong map play
and team coordination and is a wind
condition unto himself his relevance has
stretched across years and he's the
ninth most picked and ninth most
contested hero of all time that writer
has almost always been relevant in one
form or another
especially since 2013 the authoring and
ition this Abel's strong leaning and
solid damage that writers fills in
nearly every gap a team could ask for
while he was initially played mid he has
found homes in the safe Lane the offlane
and even occasionally support good
enough maybe they do another lesser that
time is the jungle with the wife and
pulled back in again
batrider everybody of a fake group on
that writer has been a topic in nearly
every meta for the past five years and
is the most contested hero ever by more
than 3000 picks and bans making him the
most statistically significant hero of
the law who Sam can just capitalize on
it and the IO shapes entire games and
entire metas around himself and has done
so for nearly five years any game in
which it is picked takes on a completely
different complexion thanks to its
global presence team sustain and catch
potential IO forces opponents to think
differently about their strategy while
giving the friendly team nearly every
conceivable advantage and as such IO has
never really fallen out of favor despite
years of Medicine's nerfs and gameplay
changes he's already got a monster kill
streak and he is a monster on the
frontlines Moody and there's tons of
they'll look for more now Osborn conga
it's gonna be the next target almost has
the feature ready to go but turn around
as they found Lana they caught him out
with the cat award and warned
combination take three and make it a
Roshan as well while iOS most prominent
time was the International 2013 where it
was famously abused by alliance to win
it all io has been in the top 12 most
contested heroes at four of the last
five internationals a testament to the
hero's longevity and used to kill the
instrument of death for his own teammate
whether you love or hate
io its statistical significance and its
impact on how competitive teams approach
each and every game cannot be
understated io is the most important
hero
in dota 2 history under the team for tau
is God pulls even out of the last Marvin
whew that was our list we're sure you
have some thoughts about it so let us
know in the comments section below
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button